Wrap a hot dog in a burger and share one
with the girl who looks like Taylor
Lautner.
It's episode 35 of IMG!
Okay, see this picture
of Albert Einstein?
Well, squint your eyes to see a wizard.
Last week a volcano erupted in Iceland
and it was captured
from space.
Octopus chandeliers are also weird,
but this is how I spend most of my
Saturdays. Once the kid is born,
pick up a TV dinner,
perfect for kid...bullying people.
I usually prefer meals like this,
complete with snails
and romance. Rage faces are everywhere,
but take a look at a dollar bill.
Closer, closer, closer,
closer. Forever alone.
Grandma...
Oh.
Here's a pilot ejecting from a plane
really close to the ground.
This is what he escaped from.
No, no, no, kitty, kitty, kitty.
That is a bad box to sleep in.
But I do love epic meetings.
Carl Sagan
and the Dalai Lama. George Harrison and
Bob Marley. Warren Buffett,
Bill Gates, Ludacris.
Hunter S Thompson,
John Cusack, Johnny Depp and a blow up doll.
Oh, and this guy with Albert Einstein,
that is Charlie Chaplin and here's
Chaplin
with Gandhi.
Oh and when bears are bald, they look like
this.
Artist Sam Spratt gave us Dwight Schrute
wearing a bear,
and he also created Rebecca Black
with rotting flesh.
Reddit discovered a lot
of truths this week. A building that looks
like a bird wearing a top hat
and Obama looks like this.
Seriously.
A lot.
And now, funny names for boats.
Enjoy.
This license
plate looks random, but in a mere
reflection... Potatoes and humans can be
friends.
And if you want a wedding ring to be
more permanent, make it a piercing.
Sam Bassett takes incredible portraits.
Randy Moss,
rainbows, tennis. And here are some books
from the Dutch literature organization
cut into three-dimensional heads,
like this one of Anne Frank.
And that's right, you guessed it,
today's final image
is this 8-bit hair bow that you can own
from today's episode of LÜT, where I cover a bunch of
stuff that you can actually buy.
And don't worry boys, there are some gifts
for you, too. So go over there right now,
click on the hair bow to view it.
Be sure to subscribe to Vsauce and
Vsauce2.
And as always,
thanks for watching.